ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show live from Chicago Illinois
broadcasting here from the heart of
America five sold-out shows at Zanies
thank you guys we're having a lot of fun
over there
also if you want to catch me in Toronto
those tickets are almost sold out but
I'll be there for Valentine's Day and if
you've seen my act you know that nothing
gets the pussy's wetter then my act I am
uh I am on act where you just [ __ ] right
afterwards maybe during so just know
that I am an act for romance so if it's
your first date or if you're trying to
rekindle the flame from a marriage that
is just gone the wrong way
especially the latter if you're in a
failing marriage my set might either
expedite that process where you just
walk out and go I don't even want to see
you again
or it might rekindle that old flame that
you had when you both met each other
years and years ago but those tickets
are Valentine's Day in Toronto I was
watching the democratic debate last
night watching what happened in Iowa is
great this is the year of who gives a
[ __ ] this is the year that the
Illuminati just doesn't care they're
just they're going balls to the wall
they're losing power their nights not
working the ruling class their it just
they don't need to disguise things the
way they used to
Epstein hung himself in the shell
the apps not tabulating votes what's the
app called it's called go [ __ ] yourself
that's what it's called it's called the
shadow app I love it it's just fun you
have to enjoy it now yes there's
elements of it they should depress you
as it is the crumbling of our civil
order to an extent but you gotta love it
the shadow app by acronym can't tabulate
the votes in the Iowa caucus they just
they don't even
take any care or concern with the name
when they're coming up with this when
Langley Virginia sends people out there
to go work in tech firms and they come
up with these [ __ ] startups Oh
Whitney Webb's written all about this
this is the future by the way this isn't
like you know this is an anomaly it's
not an anomaly all of these tech firms
are getting into voting how are we gonna
vote they're all building election
technology and it's going to be used and
manipulated so that it says whatever it
wants I'm telling you right now they're
not gonna let trump happen again they're
gonna try not to they're gonna do the
best they can to limit people's ability
to vote and and you're seeing it's just
gonna [ __ ] happen I mean it's just
kind of hilarious um you know and then
of course who all the votes go to they
go to mayor Pete mayor Pete who's the
president of a town that's not even real
South Bend Indiana is not real doesn't
exist if you go to where they say South
Bend Indiana is on a map you'll be
turned away by military police my friend
did it last week you're turned away by
military police there's a bunch of tents
and there's guys standing outside with
guns but there's no South Bend Indiana
it doesn't exist if it exists it's a
city that's built under Washington DC
that's it
tell me that right now I'm mayor Pete
who couldn't be more of a TI a shill in
that race he could not be more and I
loved like his quote were goes yeah I
had an interview with the CIA I really
botched that
didja didja Pete I've only known you for
a for a little while I think you
probably did very well he's their guy in
the race you could tell he's coming out
there with that strong neoliberal
position he loves war he's ready to you
know we gotta just keep the economy
servicing people that have billions of
dollars this is the establishment
position CIA works for the establishment
all they do essentially is paved the way
for billionaires and corporations that's
pretty much what they do it's what
they've done all over the world it's
what they do in America there's
hired guns CIA just hired guns okay
they're doing the it's not all wet work
it's not all killing people it's not all
knocking people over although some of it
is that but a lot of it is cultural it's
you know who's the guy that we're gonna
find that we're gonna blackmail or that
you know wants it so bad we don't even
have to blackmail them and somebody said
something about mayor Pete wants to me
which stuck with me this was a well
placed person in a pretty you know
established family that has money and he
said the real scary guys are the mayor
Pete's of the world they're the guys
without money and without connections
but they want it so bad
that they will do anything he said those
are the truly terrifying people you know
people that come from nowhere come from
nothing you know and a lot of these
people by the way that's how they are
thrust onto the national stage they're
the mayor of a town you've never heard
of well why do a bunch of millionaires
and billionaires love the mayor why do
they love the gay mayor of South Bend
Indiana why is that guy their their
choice what exactly about him excites a
bunch of billionaires is it that they
want the first gay president perhaps but
why why do they want the phret is it
because they they care about human
rights no it's because it's a great way
to sidestep any meaningful critiques of
somebody and this is why you have like
identity politics happening in the way
it does where we just elevate people
based on their sexuality their race
their gender and it doesn't matter what
they believe who cares what they believe
doesn't matter I you know my friend we
talked about this a comedian that we
kind of know she's like a lesbian she's
Muslim but you know when you see rock
you know what it all comes down to that
she likes hats that's all it is she
doesn't have a specific particular
perspective it's that she enjoys hats
she
about her half I like wearing hats my
friend Ryan likes hats they're the same
person they're essentially the same
person she just happens to be Pakistani
and lesbian doesn't give you a
perspective but Pete is their man in the
race you could tell you can feel it it's
is that it's your instinct and you're
correct they didn't think he was gonna
be the president they thought Biden
would get the nod or maybe Warren would
get the nod Pete was supposed to be a VP
this is what I think happened I think
Pete was gonna be a VP they want one of
their guys in the White House they want
one of them in the White House if it's
not in the Oval they want somebody the
billionaire cartels the people that own
the corporation's own the land own the
resources employ the CIA those people
want a a sympathetic ear in that
building whether it's the the vice
president or the President and Buddha
jej was the guy clean a gay guy married
South Bend Indiana Midwest served in the
Armed Forces he has the resume you know
probably turned into a CIA asset when he
was overseas maybe not who knows and
people don't understand when you're an
asset of the CIA it doesn't necessarily
mean that you're sitting down in Langley
Virginia taking orders although you
could be it means that you're on their
team and they're gonna do everything
they can to help you whether you know it
or not and and he's the dude 100% he's
the guy mayor Pete is the guy that they
want and I don't think they thought I
don't think they figured that Joe Biden
was gonna implode the way he did because
Biden is is completely senile he has no
idea what he's talking about he's
smelling the hair of children he's
making out with his niece this is what
he's doing I mean he's full throat
making out with his granddaughter on
stage no one no one knew that was gonna
happen nobody figured that they were
like well they you know he kind of kept
this under wraps during the Obama
administration but he's
deep throat [ __ ] open mouth kissing
his relatives onstage he's you know
massaging people he's a creepy old guy I
don't I don't think he's a pedophile I
just don't think he knows what's going
on anymore I think he's maybe in the
early stages of dementia I don't know
what's happening to him I just think
he's completely falling apart his senses
are crossing I don't know I don't know
why you're smelling someone's hair on a
debate stage I don't know why you're
picking up children and you know
squeezing them till they pop whatever
the problem is nobody anticipated that
that was gonna [ __ ] go as left as it
did um
Warren's unforced errors are amazing
because he you don't really there's
billionaires watching this the way that
you watch the superball they watch this
the way that you watch the Super Bowl
and they go I can't believe who is
allowing this to happen this [ __ ] took
a DNA test to prove that she was a
Native American it comes back she's not
like no one forced her to do it don't
put a gun in her mouth and force it do
it these people like the guys who own
Raytheon and General Dynamics and Boeing
they're all like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] doing she's throwing the game and
they can't have that so you gotta back a
guy like mayor Pete and I'm mayor Pete
is a cool cautious
you know cerebral guy hard to put him on
the fan but you know spent all his money
in Iowa they wanted a big showing in
Iowa but make no mistake none of this is
an accident
I don't believe that I don't believe any
of this is just happenstance
I think that part of the problem is that
people don't yet realize where we're at
because everything the economy is good
and people are largely employed even
though not a jobs that they want
the ruling class in this country is
losing power the people are turning
against the government really maybe for
the first time since the 1960s are you
seeing movements being built where the
aim is to upend the social order people
are tied Donald Trump was a wrecking
ball that people threw at the system
they didn't want Hillary they didn't
want Jeb
they don't want your Biden so if you're
a billionaire what do you what are you
to do you know you you have to find
somebody that these people are gonna
coalesce behind you have to find an
Obama you have to find somebody who is
going to have you know the gravitas to
keep the [ __ ] train running because
otherwise it gets messy Trump it's messy
Sanders it'll be messy when you have an
anti-establishment guy in there that's
willing to call out the CIA call out the
FBI when you're willing to go to those
links to totally remake society starting
with your own political party Trump
remade the Republican Party Sanders will
have to remake the Democratic Party
Democrat big Democrat donors are [ __ ]
losing their minds I know somebody who
works you know in a company with like
John Kerry's a partner and you know John
Kerry was was on the phone the other day
somebody overheard his conversation he's
like I mean why should I run what are we
gonna do like these guys are losing
their grasp on their party they're
losing their grasp on the country and
you're starting to see so then they have
to fight back they can't just they're
not gonna go quietly into the night
that's not what having billions of you
you don't amass billions of dollars by
being agreeable they're not just gonna
step aside they're gonna have to kick up
some dirt and they're gonna do
everything they can they've thrown a lot
of [ __ ] of Trump none of it is stuck
Trump is a corrupt guy he spent years
and years hold on Chicago is a [ __ ]
ambulance in Chicago every somebody shot
in Chicago
every 15 minutes so this is why there's
ambulances going on but they threw
everything at Trump nothing stock yeah
maybe when he's out of office something
will stock a stick I don't know I have
no doubt that there is corrupt dealings
that they could unearth by the way and I
have no doubt if they look at Obama or
Clinton it's the same [ __ ] thing okay
but what are they gonna throw at Bernie
so the first thing they threw at Bernie
was just kerfuffle in Iowa where an app
couldn't tabulate all the votes and the
late reporting precincts all broke for
Bernie Sanders [ __ ] you you know what
this is you know what it is Bernie could
have come if Bernie won Iowa he might
have come out of there not you know with
with a mandate it might have started to
look like the big money or the momentum
he would never have got he's not gonna
get the big money but the momentum
clearly grassroots party activists would
all kind of flow to him they've they've
bought themselves some time now now
Bernie's gonna - he's gonna win New
Hampshire then the meet he's gonna talk
about the New Hampshire doesn't really
matter this is the next thing they're
gonna do they gave me well we always
knew he was gonna win New Hampshire it
doesn't really matter we stole Iowa from
him and they're gonna hope that he gets
beaten in South Carolina or on Super
Tuesday and they're hoping and praying
to God and if by some miracle he gets
the nomination and wins then they're
going to do a version of what they're
doing to Trump he's not gonna be allowed
to govern with a mandate he's going to
be attacked from all sides you know
they're gonna have people in the
Democratic Party that are turning on him
in the same way that that Republicans
flipping on Trump this is just what
they're gonna do you might hate Trump
you might hate his politics you might
think he's a destructive force in
society all of that you can think is
true you cannot doubt that from the
minute he took office there's been a
coordinated campaign from both the media
and the intelligence agencies to
discredit this presidency 100% and if
you think it's just Trump
if you think it's not gonna be Bernie
you're out of your mind they just don't
want anybody rocking the boat and
they're gonna throw scandals at Bernie
they're gonna they're gonna you know
back people they're gonna they're gonna
turn people in his administration
against him they're gonna have people
spying I mean this is what they've done
forever she's not gonna change the the
problem is it's becoming more obvious
they're getting more desperate as you
get more desperate when you're a
criminal and you get desperate
the crimes become a you start grabbing
things you know you know the old
smash-and-grab midday in the middle of a
public park you just [ __ ] grab
somebody's pocketbook and run why cuz
you're desperate that's not a highly
organized criminal activity you know
you're [ __ ] doing what you can to
steal some votes in Iowa from this guy
but it's very interesting to watch
happen the good news for all of us is
that corporations have governed the
country for a long time it's really not
the elections as important as they are
you know if Mark Zuckerberg stepped down
at Facebook it probably has more of an
effect on people's life then you left
for now for now but it's gonna it's
gonna it's gonna ramp up and you're
gonna see just a constant fight until
the establishment can get a mayor Pete
in there until they can put an Obama
back in there until they can get
somebody who's [ __ ] just plays the
game it's just gonna keep getting worse
it's gonna keep getting obvious the
media which is now in 100% chill mode
and I mean to a point where they're
telling you your eyes and ears don't
work that's the job of the media now
they come until your eyes and ears don't
work what you just saw isn't happening
it's not happening what you just heard
isn't happening that's the job of the
media they go there's nothing to this
these conspiracy before there were
conspiracy theories about Iowa the
people on MSNBC be like ah there's
conspiracy two people think that this
shadow app is somehow connected to I
know that Mayor Pete's campaign funded
it a lot of campaigns
listen I know a lot of the people that
design the app work for Hillary Clinton
a lot of people work for Hillary clap
stop it shut up
eat your Wendy's and go to bed pig stop
reading articles stop reading reddit
threads and go to bed everything's fine
there's no conspiracy here
what do you Trump what are you a Russian
I mean this is the full-time job of the
media right now hey everybody how much
do I have to talk about Ridge wallet I
mean how much do I tell you I love Ridge
wallet I love Reggie wallet more than my
mother one of my father more than any of
my friends I'd watch them all burn to
death I'd watch them all get the
coronavirus and die if I could just have
another Ridge wallet it's so beautiful
it's so great it's a minimal front
pocket wallet that's designed to
streamline what you carry every day it
has 30,000 five-star reviews and is a
better way to carry your cash and guards
there's a lifetime warranty if you love
it and free returns if you don't it
comes in titanium carbon fiber aluminum
and over a dozen different styles and
colors okay
get 10% off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to Ridge
comm slash Jim use the promo code
dummies please my father bought a bunch
he didn't use the code it doesn't help
me god he told me you think I bought
everyone I know a ridge wall and I'm
like did you use the code and he said no
so it doesn't matter but god bless him
god love him why stop now that boomer
mentality just ride out into the sunset
with it no help for the children let
them die I'll tell you right now folks I
I before I'd orig wallet' my life is a
horror I had a big leather wallet I
would open it up business cards would
fall out it was embarrassing I was
homeless I had no money I had AIDS I
lived in the park I lived in a tent it
was disgusting I didn't I could not
bathe I had all kinds of lesions all
over my body somebody opened the tent
one day zipped it put in a ridge wallet
the day after that I looked at the ridge
wall and I'm like man this is a simple
minimal front pocket wallet and it's
gonna streamline my entire life so what
I did was I threw out all those old
business cards and I just took the Ridge
wallet
and then I said [ __ ] this is perfect
because it really only fits what I need
credit card debit card a little maybe a
hundred dollar bill take do cocaine off
a hookers ass perfect maybe a card from
my attorney
not a lot it made me pare down my life
streamline it made me start thinking
about what was important okay
one week after getting the Ridge wallet
I had a job I was a managing director at
a bank I had an apartment I had a wife I
had three children there were all three
years old they were beautiful I had a
beautiful family everyone loved me why
because I hustled I grinded how rich I
took a wallet I put it in my pocket it
changed my life
i cured myself of AIDS I do not have
lesions anymore all over my body I have
a six pack I have a beautiful body I
have a perfect penis it's seven and
three-quarters inches beautiful thick
equally at the base and the head a
beautiful head pink a perfect hue two
lovely size balls everything's perfect
and because of the ridge wallah one week
seven days after the ridge wallet I had
a beautiful family we got married we had
a honeymoon everything was perfect
all my friends came back I went to uh
you know high school reunion showed off
my pictures of my wife and kids I'm a
big managing director at a bank it was
well because you're rich wallet it's a
magic [ __ ] wallet dummy it's not just
a wallet it's magic this is a cult okay
it's a magic wallet anything you want
you want to kill someone you can do it
with a ridge you just have to you know
you have to inscribe their name and the
ridge wallet and then you could you
could curse them and then they die
Ridge comm / Tim Ridge comm slashed him
use the code Tim for the link in the
description you'll get 10% off folks you
get 10% off your dream life okay 10% off
your dream life you should pay more for
how much this thing is gonna [ __ ]
help you it's amazing thank you
the Tim Dillon show is sponsored by
Kenai progear the world is going to hell
in a handbasket you got to be ready for
battle starts with a good backpack throw
out the JanSport set your NPR tote bag
on fire
get cannae pro gear their backpacks were
inspired by military assault packs they
took military grade materials like 500d
Cordura nylon the brand name nylon which
is the strongest lightest most durable
this thing would've survived an Epstein
cell LOL god i hate this ad read lots of
great products have come out of the
military aviator glasses the jeep
wrangler and now you can you can get the
Fallon's duty pack it is in use by the
US government is trusted by Secret
Service agents trust me it's good enough
for you
so the kunai ProGear thing their Holiday
Sale is on now my code Tim T I am you
can get an additional 15% off listen
here's a deal we all know the world is
going to descend into chaos
eventually the dollars not going to be
the world's reserve currency interest
rates are gonna go up we're gonna
China's gonna stop servicing our debt
we're gonna go into a death spiral
political corruption is systemic it's a
problem it's a disease that's affected
every part of the body politic the
mistrust is not going to come back or
you're gonna see is more irregularities
with voting more distrust in the system
and eventually large-scale mass unrest
you're gonna see climate change really
caused massive problems not only for the
economy but for the social order and
what you're gonna need is a great
backpack when things go to [ __ ] it's
very true you're gonna need a good
backpack look at all those disaster
movies and that's where we're going
they all have backpacks I am Legend all
of that [ __ ] they all have backpacks
they walk around and they put things
they need in them like guns
I'm telling you society's gonna crumble
she's gonna fall at least partially and
you're gonna need a good bag
pack so this is this is smart cani is
smart it's a smart company that they're
they're they're marketing for the end
that's what I like that's what I love
about capitalism market for the end even
in the end times you need a durable back
you just need it it's important if you
don't have it you're gonna get caught
you don't want to be caught so if you go
to kunai ProGear that's c-a-n-n-a II Pro
gear.com use Tim to get 15% off
c-a-n-n-a II Pro gear.com used him to
get 15% off after the bombs there will
only be you and can i pro gear it's true
I like it as much as I make fun of the
ad copy they understand what they're
selling they're selling a backpack to
Psychopaths that listen to my show
whether they're on the far right or the
far left because we have we have proud
boys in the audience we have an tyfa
we have communists we have fascists we
have Nazis we have black bloc we've got
everybody we've got we run the gamut the
far left to the far right we have you
know Epstein obsessives we have ever
seen truthers probably we would do the
whole thing we have people that believe
that the you know the 911 buildings were
Holograms
we have people believe that the month of
September doesn't exist it is what the
[ __ ] it is and we're happy for them
can i ProGear get the [ __ ] get the
backpack don't not have a backpack when
everything goes to [ __ ] don't do it it
makes you long for the days when
everybody was just checked out the days
where I grew up my first experience in
Chicago was my my friend we we met a
woman who had an impact on our life when
we were children uh and not children but
we were in our early 20s we were
children we were young kids we didn't
know the ways of the world and we were
in a bar in East Meadow Long Island
called Duggan's which used to have
really good wings and I'm sure it still
does but we were there and
we were all boozed up we were all [ __ ]
up having fun and this woman attractive
in his stripper esque quality you know
she was hot not beautiful but hot she
was there was you know there was a
sexual energy to her she was just you
know she was down for it she was that
type of woman she was dancing on the bar
at Duggan's and then my friend Joe who
was about maybe at that point a little
under 300 pounds also got on a bar and
he was dancing at Duggan's and but it
but truly light on his feet like a
Jackie Gleason and he just missed
falling off the bar and he was so
hammered he didn't know what he was
doing but just graceful like a like a
figure skater just the grace of him
dancing was really something to see we
all just stood there and stared at him
because it was like amazing to watch and
this girl dancing on the bar as well
finally got off the bar and she came
over to me and she goes who's this fat
[ __ ] and she pointed to him I was a guy
that's my friend Joe and she'd met us a
few times we knew her she was she was
friends with some of our friends she had
a presence in Levittown Long Island
Levittown is the first suburb in the
country and you know there was a lot of
promise there post-world War two and now
it's mostly you know flea markets and
heroin but you know that's what it is
now and that's what it was starting to
become that it was just a suburban you
know it's trashy you know one guy said
once to me you know one of the kids we
knew in Levittown we walked into his
little Leavitt house I think his dad put
like a new Peugeot wood floor like fake
wood man they loved that over there they
loved fake wood cuz you could drop
things on it and spill things on it and
you know you could have fistfights in
the room and nothing would ever affect
the quality of the
flooring so this guy gets a Peugeot wood
floor which cost about $500 and then he
said to me he goes my dad put a new
floor in this house he raised the value
of the house fifty thousand dollars and
I my people didn't that didn't the fluff
Jesus [ __ ] does that read on the thing
okay it just drives me nuts the sirens
drive me nuts here I mean it's just
[ __ ] insane we're gonna get we'll be
back in the studio this is uh you know
we couldn't record a podcast we're
announcing a 34 week tour it's a you
know there's a lot going on here but
this idiot then explained to me that his
house was now worth $100,000 more money
because his dad spent $500 in a fake
wood floor and I tried to tell him that
that wasn't true and he just stared at
me and then you realize it like you
couldn't get through to these people
they were just they were just biological
waste you know that's really what they
were you just stared at them and you
were like okay sure you know whatever
you want um but we met this woman and
she started dating my friend and and
immediately she was a world wind it was
just fights and problems and websites
that her name was mentioned on were
people that accused her of all kinds of
things like writing fake checks and
stealing their money and and and being a
con artist
I liked her immediately I really liked
her immediately there was something
about her I enjoyed she was a lot of fun
to go out to dinner with she was a real
con you know she worked people over she
had dudes in different towns it took
their [ __ ] money and I think that's
great I support all of that and yes she
was ruining my friend's life but
someone's gotta ruin your life that's
really what it comes down to someone has
to come into your life and destroy it
unless you'll do it yourself somebody's
got to come in with a big dick or a wet
[ __ ] and destroy your ability to make
decisions they'll destroy your
relationship with your family they'll
destroy your motivation your ability to
work at your job
they'll put distance between you and
your closest friends someone needs to do
that you don't live a full life
unless you've
someone where you literally will follow
them into like some now you know a lot
of people don't don't don't go that
route which is fine too and they have
other things and whatever but most
people in the world you're just waiting
for that to happen you want to meet
somebody who will just you could just
you know just say [ __ ] you mom and dad
if you don't like this person you don't
get them you don't understand them so
that's what it is you're either gonna
destroy your own life or someone's gonna
do it for you that's the way this world
works that's all it'll be drugs it'll be
alcohol it'll be food it'll be sex it'll
be your own ambition it'll be money
it'll be your [ __ ] ungrateful
children it'll be the job that didn't
give a [ __ ] about you it'll be some
soulless multinational corporation that
you spent 45 years in that one day you
just go in and you've got a gun in your
pocket your [ __ ] pants and you're
ready to just blow everybody's head off
you know who knows it's gonna be one of
those things it might as well be a
stripper from Chicago it might as well
be a cocaine addict from the suburbs of
Chicago why not great tits why not
it's gonna be something it's gonna be a
bad real estate deal you did with your
brother-in-law something's gonna get you
don't get out of it alive folks it
doesn't matter make your mistakes young
and he did and my friends made their
mistakes young and you know old
middle-age but we met her and she was
immediately a world wind she was
immediately somebody who came in full
force had opinions about everybody about
everything you know I saw this my dad I
mean my dad's wife came into his life
my dad had one failed marriage she came
in she's like this is the way your life
is gonna be run and my dad's Irish and
Irish men marry their mothers and he
goes okay good
I need a mother I need someone to come
in and tell me what to do where's the
washer and dryer how does all of it work
when do we pay our bills the first of
the month okay I'll try that for years
and years we've been paying him when
whenever we could but we'll try to pay
them on the first honey that's a good
idea she came in and just cleaned it up
you know this woman came in I don't want
to say her name
the surname we're gonna call her because
this we use her nickname our nickname we
called her Blagojevich because rod
Blagojevich was uh I believe the
governor of Illinois and rod Blagojevich
of course was a shady guy and I think
he's in jail right now and Liguria vich
yeah he was an American politician the
40th governor of Illinois and then he
was impeached convicted and removed from
office in 2009 and uh you know he was
you know from you know I mean Chicago is
just the most corrupt state in the Union
he was removed from office for
corruption bribes all of that stuff you
know it says Levitch was impeached and
removed he solicited bribes for
political appointments including Barack
Obama's vacant US Senate seat after
Obama was elected president fun so he's
was sentenced to 14 years in federal
prison so for the rest of this will just
call this woman blue Goya fish because
you know she was from Chicago
she played fast and loose with the truth
but again she was a fun person not
always
she had tantrums and things she'd go out
to bars and fight people you know she
was one of those people it's one of
those people you'd go to a bar and you'd
be having a cigarette outside and all
the sudden she'd be being thrown out by
the bouncers you know you know I'd go
where's she wears blue goya vich and
then she's in a headlock two guys are
walking her outside you know she wasn't
Jackie Kennedy sure um but my friend you
know his parents you know being boomers
they were just kind of like letting it
happen they realized like I did that you
know that generation of people from Long
Island those boomer parents they they
were not helicopter parents I'll tell
you that much it wasn't like the Asian
tiger balm were they they were just like
hey let it happen you know we lived our
life we had our journey you're gonna
have yours you know and that was it it
was kind of hands-off I'm the guy that's
featured for me now is on the phone his
dad the other day and it was so nice and
his father was so invested in what he
was doing and wanted to know about
everything he was doing and it's like oh
that's what parenting is supposed to be
and my friends and a lot of our parents
they were they were they were wild
people they were fun they were big
personalities
but you know it was about them they were
they were invested in that not whole
generation of people they were just
invested in them and their kids were in
the picture but weren't the picture and
I remember this this woman and they you
know like many of these relationships
they break up they get back together
they break up they get back together she
goes to jail you know how relationships
are folks you get back together somebody
goes to jail for identity theft you get
out of jail you got a little coke you
put some of that on the street you make
a little money you lose a little money
you have to go back to [ __ ] some other
guy you don't know and you [ __ ] write
some fake checks you know you take his
credit card you take an advance on that
you're bouncing around you get it it's
relationships that's what they are
they're all deals we're all making deals
every minute of the day she was always
up to something you know phone
conversations and parking lots where no
one could hear her that type of stuff a
fun woman again someone that I watched
from afar and up close I had no real
investment in the outcome I didn't want
her to murder my friend but I knew that
that was a possibility and that would
have been okay to not that I wanted him
to die but sometimes people make a
choice and they can't unmake it you got
to follow it to its logical conclusion
we always used to kid around you know
she had an older grandmother and we said
she's gonna kill that woman
she's gonna push that woman down the
stairs to try to inherit money or
something we always believed that and we
thought my friend would go along with it
we go he'll probably do it too it's just
what they have to do sometimes you can't
get in the way of somebody's story
sometimes you can't sit down with
someone and go listen you have to be a
good moral person it would be a waste of
their time not everybody's here to do
that
some people are here not for a long time
but for a good time they're gonna have a
little fun they're gonna make it
interesting there what you're gonna talk
about in the diner while you're eating
your eggs you're gonna read about them
in the paper some people need to be that
person and you can't get in their way so
many of you are moralist it's so boring
oh stop doing drugs stop stealing money
don't be a [ __ ] Oh
[ __ ] you some people find that that's
the only way they can feel free the only
way they can feel alive it's really not
my business it's truly not my business
I'd rather you not abuse children you
know I'd rather you not but I will say I
think this woman for all of her you know
negatives was a decent mother you know
she had kids from many different races
she was woke what I'm thinking is when I
remember her I remember just somebody
who when you were with her anything
could happen you know just you just felt
I mean and I literally mean anything and
I remember one day we were sitting in my
friend's home in Long Island and the
state police showed up about four cars
and they knocked on the door and they
said is Blagojevich there they didn't
use that word they used a real name my
friend Ryan was like no I don't what who
and they said well this is how you were
cuz at that time she was on Indiana's
most wanted she was on a list of people
from Indiana's most wanted for fake
checks
I think identity theft things like that
just the most wanted they they wanted
her in other words and they were coming
and my friend opened the door cuz we
knew you never know the level of
skullduggery someone's involved with
especially somebody like her she was
kind of a pro almost a pro like she was
pretty damn good at what she did she
wasn't great at it she's in jail now
because she got a few dealies but she
was pretty [ __ ] you know the state
police showed up and I said hey where's
blue guava ch and he was like she's not
here and they said listen this is how it
works we have a warrant for the property
we're gonna go in and if we find her
you're gonna go away as an accessory
because that's how this works so I'm
gonna ask you one more time where is she
and my friend just looked at them and he
went she's in the kitchen and they got
her they took her away and I remember my
friend's father he said you know it was
scary about it he goes you know it was
really
disturbing he goes you guys your big
[ __ ] guys you know my friends like a
bodybuilder type coddling I because you
guys are big [ __ ] guys he goes if
State Police had showed up to take you
guys to jail you would have been
panicked he goes you would have seen it
in your face he goes this [ __ ] showed
no emotion she just walked the [ __ ] out
of the house stone-cold he goes she's a
career criminal I remember having dinner
with them and he goes she's a career
criminal and I was just would just
drinking martinis and eating and they
were trying to make him understand but
not for that long because then you know
they started talking about buying condos
and you know in Florida and you know the
boomers baby they were just basically
like now more importantly our son might
be dating somebody on the most-wanted
list but let's discuss condos let's
discuss how we can get out of here how
we can get away let's plan our escape um
but she was an amazing uh fun lady I
remember the first time I was in Chicago
because that's where she came from came
from the suburbs her mother ran a
business her mother had money they had
money that a big house in the suburbs
dad [ __ ] money she didn't come from
yeah this wasn't she had just enough
money to know she wanted more money and
you know she just couldn't live the you
know straight life just wasn't in her
she just wanted it's a scam or a con she
wanted somebody to work over she wanted
to just put money in her pocket that
wasn't hers you know that's just what
she got off on doing you know and my
friend you know came from from some
money and I think she thought this is a
this is a great way to kind of just
purge myself you know next to somebody
that has a little money and that also
you know is you know my friend also you
know morally bankrupt and in you know I
mean like dude extent we were all drug
addicts you know world doing drugs we
were all you know the we weren't exactly
you know upstanding members of society
so she never felt uncomfortable with us
but I remember we drove to Blagojevich's
house to give her
dogs because her and my friend Hajus
this is true uh guy had left they became
friends with this guy he went to Europe
for a year and and they were I think
maybe supposed to get his mail or
whatever they just moved into his
apartment they just moved into his
apartment and started living there and
then until that scam was up and they
were thrown out of that so these are
just their grifters they were living in
someone else's apartment I I mean I came
over I go whose homelessness God some
guy we're just living here he had no
idea they were living in his [ __ ]
apartment so they when that when that
unfortunately when that was you know one
that when time was up on that scam she
went back to Chicago you know my friend
during this time is like working for
gyms in Long Island which would I don't
even know what that means that means
just selling HGH in the parking lot of
an Applebee's and she is doing you know
odd jobs I mean I don't know that she
ever had a job she was dancing I think
she was stripping she was all over the
place and so we take this road trip with
these two dogs to Chicago and we visit
the house of blue Goya [ __ ] and we meet
Blagojevich's mother and this woman was
wild 300 pounds if she was a pound pack
of Marlboro menthol lights mocha
frappuccino Grande every day in a big
[ __ ] truck I was in the front seat
with her and she was just screaming on
an ex telling somebody I think she was
in trucking or whatever she was just
wild she was just a tough [ __ ] and that
was blue koi [ __ ] mother I was like
this is a [ __ ] this is a wild family
her dad I don't remember her dad at all
which either means he was like a
soft-spoken guy or I don't know but the
mom was the dominant force in the house
a no-nonsense take-no-prisoners [ __ ]
would build the business [ __ ] you she
knows money
she knew her business inside and out
don't [ __ ] with her type of lady
respected the hell out of her only knew
her for a few hours really
but enjoyed her you know
then and you know we hung out it would
say Patrick's Day we all got dragged
drunk you know they died the river green
you know and my friend and me drop the
dogs off and then we went home and uh it
was a [ __ ] really interesting
relationship to watch it ended as they
do as these things do you know my
friends started dating another woman
from Long Island and they started doing
heroin and this girl had a few TVs and
is serving I think almost a decade in
prison right now and it's sad that those
things happen you know it's unfortunate
but what I have wanted in another way
would I have wanted it another way the
answer is no because we just have to let
things happen what I have wanted you
know them to be you know missionaries
for the church going around and trying
to show people the light of Christ I
don't know no they were fun people and
sometimes when you have a lot of fun in
life you pay a little bit of a price
I've paid a price we've all paid a price
and so my message out there is if you
have fun people in your life and I mean
truly fun people not like fun people
like oh my god jelly is so fun she's a
few drinks and she makes everyone dance
I mean really fun people Indiana's most
wanted State Police people getting
arrested front-page news articles you
won't leave your wallet in the room with
them you think your phone might be
tapped that type of person their family
pulls you aside when you walk into their
house and go you should stay the [ __ ]
away from them that kind of friendship
that kind of fun if you have one of
those keep your distance be smart but
also don't try to make them into
something they're not it just isn't
going to work it's not going to work
they know who they are and they're
they're leaning in there having the
journey they need to have maybe later on
in life they realized the errors of
their ways I'm sure you know whatever
I'm not saying go out there and hurt
people but if you know somebody and
they're a con artist a cheater a grifter
a derelict but they're fun at dinner
it's so important to be fun I didn't go
out with a substitute teacher and listen
to her mouth listen to her talk about
grading papers and parent-teacher
conferences and you will run back to
somebody who's on the most-wanted list
if just for the [ __ ] story you're
only on this planet once how bored do
you want to be how meaningless do you
want all of your interactions to be you
gotta find some people that spice it up
you do and that was who this one that
was Blagojevich she was spice my friend
would call me you know our other friend
not the one that was dating her but
another guy he'd be like yeah man he's
like she's in real trouble now they got
her on this and that but somehow she's
out she made bail she's back out we're
all gonna go to dinner I go great you
know fun
I don't know listen I don't judge I mean
you know we all do in our own way but
you just gotta let it happen folks she
was a fun woman I feel bad that she's in
jail now I feel bad that that prompt
that negatively impacts her family I
feel bad that my friend did went on and
started doing heroin I don't like any of
those things they're not good things but
my role in that situation was nothing it
was simply to watch many of you think
you're too powerful this is the problem
you think you're too powerful that
people give a [ __ ] what you say they're
not they don't and you're not sit back
relax let it let it run its course it's
gonna go where it's good
go anyway your opinion notwithstanding
your little sit down not with so you can
have a talk with someone you're gonna
have a talk with them you're gonna
straighten it out you're gonna go you
know you know you should not keep doing
coke with this stripper it's got a hot
box and you [ __ ] you should know you
gotta you gotta just rein it in and slow
it down you're livin - no it's stop
you're wasting your time you're wasting
your time what'd you say to them is what
he got some coke on the street are you
making any money
let me get involved be smart obviously
don't be the guy handed people badge but
go in there with a few bucks see if you
could turn your money around flip a
little money yes I'm telling you if you
get the chance you should sell cocaine
not serious about that or am i I don't
know I don't know your life it's not my
again none of it is my business
me cute do you love a good rom-com
there's a new podcast called meet-cute
making short scripted rom-coms and take
you from meet cute to happily ever after
in just 15 minutes
eat man no one I loved before this head
read was bought no one listened to this
show each meet-cute story is made up of
five three-minute chapters their mission
is to give you a much-needed burst of
happiness and hope these stories fit in
your earbuds and anywhere in your day
you can find meet-cute on your favorite
podcast platform or wherever you listen
to audio including Spotify and Apple
podcast meet-cute already as a library
of stories waiting for you featuring
diverse characters standing in
storylines news stories drop every
Monday Wednesday and Friday subscribe to
meet cute and follow them on Instagram
to stay up to date with the latest love
stories well there you have it you can't
be dark all the time folks sometimes you
need to you need to go out there and and
find some some light some hope some love
and that's where you go to meet cute
meet cute I mean what is this I don't
even know what you can find a meet-cute
on your favorite podcast platform yes
it's a podcast and they have a library
of stories waiting for your featuring
diverse character settings and story
line I mean I wonder is this like porn
are you jacking it to this is this
something that's like when you listen to
it you're like I don't even know or is
it just like a Ron I guess I just
rom-com like love II like romantic
comedy made in manhattan J Lo's the maid
she meets a white guy blah blah blah
isn't that the plot of that I think it
is right I think it's that type of [ __ ]
I would love to advertise porn podcasts
on here I think that might be a little
better for my audience but meet-cute as
a library of stories waiting for you
ladies love stories it's made up of five
three-minute chapters so each story is
made up of five three-minute chapters I
should do a meet I just did a meet-cute
I just told you a lovely story about my
two friends who met each other and had a
great relationship which as many Long
Island relationships ended in jail and
heroine meet-cute five three-minute
chapters be great the meet-cute story
Geoffrey and just lame Geoffrey and just
lame he was a successful banker from New
York City with a checkered past she was
a British socialite whose father was an
asset of the Israeli intelligence
service he was a shoe her father was a
media mogul she had a keen eye for men
that just needed a little polish she met
Geoffrey meet-cute they knew they liked
each other immediately they started a
business trafficking children to the
wealthy elite of the world they started
they started a start-up servicing
billionaire pedophile Satanists wild
meet-cute I don't know who that is for
this meet-cute um you know when you it
could be four listen maybe it's great I
haven't listened rom-coms can be funny I
should listen to it I don't know his for
uh but you know what it is you should
check it out I'm actually gonna check it
out out of pure curiosity
because I don't want to I don't want to
like I'm curious as to what you can do
in three minutes and there's five
chapters five three-minute chapters and
I'm wondering will they let me do my
version of a love story on me cute I'm
guessing no but I would like to do a
little scripted three-minute story and I
just don't understand I don't understand
why I can't do that
meet-cute I love that the first hat is
like get a backpack to overthrow the
government second ad think it scare it
do you want KITT do you want rom-coms
sure it's nice I don't know what to tell
you ma'am go check it out
you know morbid curiosity it might be
[ __ ] grave it might be great or not
we'll say goodbye I just had a
conversation the other day with somebody
about this particular situation and
they're like you know we should have
done more we should have said more we
should watch what are you gonna say it's
obvious what's gonna happen we all know
what's gonna have you don't start dating
a stripper and think that it's gonna
work out it's not gonna work out but
it's gonna be fun doesn't anyone care
about fun anymore
doesn't anyone want to be entertained
doesn't anyone wanna be in a car with
somebody who's committed multiple
felonies and will continue to it's good
listen you can't do it your whole life
you got to grow up I'm 35
it's not fun anymore it's a lot of fun
in your early 20s be friends with
criminals in your early 20s it's worth
it in your late teens and early 20s be
friends with criminals it's valuable
watch the way they live and work it's
fun it's not all bad the life of crime
is not all bad there's some value to it
you got to understand that you got to
understand it because you know in the
society that we live really everything's
a crime everything's a hustle
everything's fake before it's real it's
all [ __ ] first right you want to be
an investor
want to be uh you know in real estate
you want to be this you want to be that
whatever you want to be you're not that
when you start and eventually you have
to become that and I think you can get a
lot of inspiration from criminals you
can get a lot of inspiration from people
that literally have to do everything
themselves criminals get very little how
unless they work on Wall Street they get
very little help from the government
everything's a grassroots operation I
mean this woman had to knock over men
on her own time she learned all those
skills it's not nothing it's not nothing
to do you know to be wanted for identity
theft in several states it means you had
a little bit of an operation going you
know learn from these people
you don't want to emulate their
activities per se but there's something
refreshing about a criminal somebody
who's there to take your money and rob
you somebody who doesn't have any moral
said sees life as a zero-sum game they
want to claw your eyes out take
everything from you they just try to
that's why they're so good in bed that
you're trying to [ __ ] their soul out
they don't have one they're trying to
feel something and they can't you know
you know the people that are the best
[ __ ] aren't the people you're
necessarily gonna marry you know but
they are the people where you should
probably hide your wallet or at least
lock it up until they leave these are
people that you need to spend a little
time with you shouldn't have an entire
existence on planet Earth okay without
fraternizing with a few of these people
you might not want to get too deep I got
a little too deep with some of these
people because I was a druggie and drugs
make you sloppy
they make you reckless but you should
observe life you should it shouldn't all
you know I talked to elite so I took the
guys go to Ivy League schools and their
lives all they've spent their whole
[ __ ] life from the lacrosse team to
the [ __ ] Ivy League school to the
private club they go to with their dad
it's all the same [ __ ] people how
boring is that don't you want to be
doing coke in a pay-by-the-hour motel in
Tampa yes you do you want to have a full
life I love the fact that I spent many
years of my life doing cocaine in and in
you know
chillie flophouses I mean you know it's
a it's I look back on I would not have
traded that for the world I really would
not have it's the best education I've
ever got criminals are interesting you
can't you know you shouldn't be a
criminal if you're not good at it but
they're an interesting type of people
and you realize that it's not all the
government's not awesome program that's
gonna fix everything you make everything
fair and equitable and nobody's gonna
commit crime [ __ ] you you want to live
in that world you want to live in a
world where nobody's trying to [ __ ] you
over god can you imagine fear is good
it's good to know that people want to
kill you it's it's incredibly healthy
I've always maintained that you can yes
you shouldn't be overly paranoid and you
shouldn't be overly cynical but you
should also realize that people are
trying to kill you both of those things
can exist in your head both thoughts
simultaneously they can both be true
this is just the nature of the beast
it's the nature what human beings are
our lives were enhanced by Blagojevich
lacoya which was fun she kept us on our
toes she kept us looking at four
detectives in our rearview mirror who's
gonna get her somebody's gonna get her
they always get got just the way it is
most of them end up in a shell but you
know if you're lucky enough if you're
lucky enough you'll know them for a
brief period of time and they'll enrich
your life with their chaos with their
insanity with their scams and their
scheming they'll make it fun they'll
give you a story to tell on a podcast
while you're in Chicago waiting to do
shows you know they'll give you someone
to read about in the papers later on
when you check up on them you go oh yeah
again you never knew her I didn't know
what kind of person she was I mean I
mean inside I mean on the outside she
was a bad person and on the inside she
was also probably also bad but I didn't
know that I never got close to her that
close I was always around her but you
could be always around people and not
we know them you know but just don't
necessarily don't exclude criminals from
your inner circle I think it's a big
mistake I think you know trust me mayor
Pete doesn't all those [ __ ] people
that are funneling money into his
campaign criminals they're a lot better
at it you know they don't get D Wiis and
end up in jail you know they don't get
you know take it out of a Long Island
kitchen by the SWAT team but criminals
nonetheless no politician says no to
criminals they all love criminals
because the richer criminal is it's so
easy you know the redemptive powers of
society are just they just work it's
like well you know when somebody has a
lot of money they're allowed to make
some mistakes you know fudge a few
things blur a few lines there's still a
good person
they've done a lot for their community
you know they've just made a few errors
errors in judgment errors in judgment
that's what it is
so under state you can't understand
America without understanding crime what
what and I don't mean you know low-level
desperate street crime
I mean institutional criminality crime
people that are willing to find ways to
subvert the democratic process to get
around the law this is what we've done
forever you know the Wild West the Mafia
we love criminals who respect them we
have them on our walls in our house we
idolize them we watch films about them
because what do they represent down deep
they represent freedom freedom to do
whatever the [ __ ] they want to build
their own empire to not have a boss to
not take any [ __ ] from anyone to not
have to worry about your family or your
friends to be able to protect people you
know to be an outlaw these are the
things they represent no in reality
that's not always the case
in fact it's rarely the case but it's
what they represent what they represent
we like that we like
Tromp we liked Rob's a criminal she's a
criminal it's a big real estate
developer with a bunch of buildings in
Manhattan he's done business with a ton
of shady people his entire career we
liked that [ __ ] yeah he can say whatever
he wants he live in a big gold apartment
and just fire off tweets from the
[ __ ] he's a boss he's a mob boss he's
a Don we love that [ __ ] we love it so
even if you don't want to be friends
with criminals up close don't come to me
and say that I'm some type of hypocrite
I mean not hypocrite or that you don't
be a hypocrite you say that I'm over
simplifying things know you love
criminals too why do you think you watch
all those Martin Scorsese movies you
love them you just don't want to see
what it really is what it truly is you
just like criminals when there when
there are you know done up in movies
when it's Hollywood but I like the
organic version the grass roots you know
the people that are just getting started
and unfortunately Blagojevich she never
made it to you know really [ __ ]
people over you know inheriting that
company your mother ran and you know
really get involved at some
import/export [ __ ] getting mobbed up you
know maybe one day maybe one day it'll
happen we don't know but she was what
I'll think I'll always think about her
when I think about Chicago I'll always
think about that period of my life you
know sort of this lawless corrupt
individual that came to symbolize an
entire city I like her you know I feel I
would I you know I would I'd spring her
out of jail if I could I can't but I
would I get her my friend together we go
to Miller's L house in Levittown have a
nice little reunion you know because
that's what it's all about but I can't
do that and I'll probably never see them
again that's the way life also works but
you know I don't regret spending time
you know
with a real with a real one she was a
real one you know I hope one day
somebody who knows her listens to this
and you know don't be mad at her she was
just going she was just going where she
was going stop getting in people's way
let them live your life stop getting it
we all know the woman that like gets
excited when someone falls down in a
train station cuz they can help you know
that woman is you see it in her face the
woman who wants to be in control of
everything she also wants to be seen as
like a helper so you know you have one
of them in your family as soon as some
something happens she goes into like
this mode where she's like let's go
right now I'll help you go there secure
the perimeter I'm gonna get him you know
this person is she wants to help and she
also wants to be the boss she wants
control that's what she wants she she
only comes alive when tragedy happens
you see this person she perks right up
car accident boom she's ready to go she
darts out the door she's ready to she
wants to cradle somebody's head in their
arms that's who that's what a lot of
people are a lot of people out there
just want to help not to truly help
because they just want control they want
to feel alive they want to feel
important but what you have to do is
just let it [ __ ] go
so in closing here folks I think we've
we've learned a little bit your youth is
supposed to be from making mistakes
surrounding yourself with the wrong
people [ __ ] some of those people
pushing you know the boundaries of where
you should be become friends with very
rich people become friends with very
poor people become friends with people
that don't follow the rules break the
rules yourself occasionally if you can
you know you can face the consequences
become friends with people that are fun
laugh do the wrong thing every now and
then there's a singer that I like who
said she goes I don't do things for the
moral of the story I do them for the
story
and I think that's that's where I've
come around to on begoy evich just a
great American story a girl raised
wealthy no reason for her to behave the
way she did not zero none that makes it
all the more fun that makes it fun if
she was a desperate girl coming from the
project who needed to do this it would
be sad but this story's fun because she
comes from an upper middle-class
upbringing and she still wanted to go
into the dark corners of the world
that's a fun broad beautiful idyllic
suburban home business she could have
stepped into and ran but [ __ ] it there
was just something there something dark
something a thirst that needed to be
quenched you know and you realized the
limits of you know good Googlers and God
bless Bernie Sanders I hope you get
everyone free college half of them won't
go what are you gonna do that show up
put a gun in their hand the problems in
this country are our you know their
institutional but they're also personal
they're also personal I don't know
exactly how you're gonna you gonna turn
this whole thing around you're probably
not gonna but when I saw that big ID
like suburban home that she came from
and then where she decided to go and the
places that she wanted to spend her time
you started understanding that sometimes
people there's just an itch inside of
them that they need to scratch and and
and sometimes they're gonna scratch it
so much that you're just gonna start
bleeding and bleed to death it's what
happens and you really can't get in the
way of that if you try too hard to stop
those people you will get involved with
those people and become those people and
then their Horrors become your Horrors
that's the problem and maybe that's what
you wanted anyway maybe all the help you
were trying to give them is because you
just want the chaos and the drama
because you thrive on it and you want to
do it but you don't want to steal
anyone's identity but you like the idea
that you're in this train wrecks life
step back watch it
like you watch Ozark you try to help the
people on Ozark know why because they're
not real just like this just like
anything it's not real it's just a story
being written somewhere and you have no
control over it the writers decide
what's gonna happen they decide who dies
who lives who goes to jail and you just
watch it and the minute you try to
involve yourself in it even in the
crusade of moralism I'm gonna do good
I'm gonna you become you become the
story you can't tell the story if you
become the story so step back get away
walk the other way there's a few people
in life that you truly love and you
truly care about and I'm telling you
right now don't even help them because
you'll hurt them you'll hurt them if you
help them if someone you know Falls and
you hear them screaming and I literally
mean this if you hear an elderly person
that you know screaming put on put in
your ear pods and just just listen to
durga god there's you two juicy juicy
and eventually the screaming will stop
because that person will have either
given up or they'll die but it was never
your business anyway you know people
make their own decisions it's not a big
[ __ ] deal you know you know god bless
lukovitch you know hopefully your kids
turn out great they will the family has
money it'll be fine
or not again not not my thing not my
thing my friend good guy love him he'll
straighten himself out or he won't again
not my thing you try you try you try you
try and then trying gets boring it gets
boring you know maybe some people's
destiny is to just Bonnie and Clyde ride
out in a hail of bullets and you're
getting in the way of that you're
getting the way of that because you want
them to go have brunch
leave them alone let them do what
they're gonna do don't necessarily you
know keep your distance but enjoy the
ride
true the ride out there you know that's
all it is
that's what the billionaire's do enjoy
the ride they manage it when they can
they manage to get in but the end of the
day what happens happens Tim Neela
comedy comm live dates we're back in the
studio next week all the episodes you've
gotta be in the studio going forward
this was just a very long week in
Chicago doing a lot of shows there was
not much we could do in terms of that
Tim Dylan comedy calm for all live dates
and I hate recording not in the studio I
just love being in the studio now that
we have it we're gonna make it better
we're excited Jamie Vernon Rogen's guys
gonna come help us do a few things
we're pumped about that you stay pumped
about it too and we'll be back on
YouTube so don't [ __ ] complain and
whine and there's no video you know
every week from now on we'll be video
this is just one week we could not make
it [ __ ] happen
but you know go steal someone's identity
folks go go try their life on see how it
works go have some fun or at the very
least go find someone who's done that
and take them to dinner it'll be fun and
that's what we're here to do just have a
little fun goodbye